teamLab started in 2001
as an art collective.
I created it as a place
for various experts
to come together and experiment.
Those experts range from
international artists and architects
to programmers and mathematicians
seeking to navigate
the convergence of art,
science, tech and the natural world.
I launched it while I was
in grad school.
I studied sciences, specializing
in physics and mathematics.
Like now, if you capture
the world through a lens
the screen sets the boundary between
your body and the cut out world.
The point of view is fixed and what to
focus on is already determined.
To explore what it means
not to be constrained,
Toshiyuki opened the world's
first digital art museum in Tokyo
aptly called teamLab Borderless.
And he says advancements in
technology has been the key
to greater freedom of expression.
From experimenting with
interactive installations
to having visitors step into water
teamLab has wowed people
all over the world in more than 50 cities.
When we hinge our artistic
expressions on physical items,
it's difficult to show change.
I think when we free ourselves
from those material items,
we can express the act of change
and even the flow of time itself.
One of its most tucked
away museums can be found
in a forest in southern Japan.
teamLab's Digitized Nature
project explores how digital tech
can turn nature into
art without harming it.
This forest has been here
for a really long time.
The garden was created
back in the Edo period.
It's a historic place where people have
lived from generation to generation
and has accumulated much meaning.
I want people to come here to feel the
long continuity of life
through our various artworks.
teamLab has no plans to slow down,
set to open a new museum in Abu Dhabi
focused on the concept of
environmental phenomena,
slated to open in 2024.
Toshiyuki says digital
technology has made it possible
for artworks to expand physically,
which allows for manipulating
and using much larger spaces.
That way, viewers are able
to experience the artwork
much more directly,
now and in the future.